so the market have a question how come I
have to be alone in Marwan
to me it's been a journey this year has
been oh your 2019 is going to be huge I
mean the projects are just like status
absolutely they can't get better than
2018 hahahaha what toast just for you
you know I had a conversation with my
mom two days ago she was with me and the
sets and the set of Hobbes and Shaw and
I sat down with her and I looked at her
and I said I am scared and she said what
do you mean and I said I'm just scared
that this is gonna be the end like I'm
still a woman I'm still insecure and I
fear you know when you're like this is
too good to be true I just I'm so
determined and I always want to do the
best job as I can and such a
perfectionist and I'm like if I don't
and I feel like people are gonna be
disappointed in me and all i care is
representing latina women in a way that
they feel proud if so that is daunting
too but she just you know had it that's
the beauty about how they have all of
that their mom who supported yeah she's
a key for success you know all that
matters baby is to be a good person make
the biggest mistake of your lives and
what's that
under estimating Who I am my mentors
Robert Rodriguez and he brought me into
this industry and has taken care of me
and I just think that we have to live in
a more compassionate world you're
teaming up so would Robert Rodriguez
again and Aleta yeah yeah there you go
and so I'm really excited for that to be
to you guys to be teaming up for that
but then James Cameron yes on board did
you ever imagine working with him and
how did you feel in that moment I never
did I think that for me as my career has
gone forward I'm driven actress in the
sense of like to me there's no small
roles yes surely to means all about
working with people that inspire me I
mean why would I even ever pass on
working with someone like James Cameron
and so like a Nolita battle angel I get
to do this special performance and it's
like a small thing comparable speaking
but what excited me was the first time
that I would like get to do motion
caption and then which introduced me and
prepped me to welcome to Marwan so it's
Eden there's no experience that will not
leave you open I create a longer
relationship with James Cameron and
longer relationship with everyone that I
worked with and I got to portray a
character what I'd not necessarily had
to be anything look related to a Latina
woman and that's what I also want to do
is branch out and sort of show and
broadcast that Latina women are
everything it can be you know the
typical Adelita which is like a very
typical Mexican woman but I can also be
a cyborg and I can't you'll be putting
up a worldly woman yeah like it's funny
you Google some actresses and says
actress but if you google me it's like
Mexican actress and that's what the
stereotype that I want to break with and
as an actress that's my agenda and if
that means taking smaller roles that is
gonna help to get to that place and be
seen in a different light yeah and be
like oh she went and did this but then
and went and did that and then that to
me is the ideal can I get a lover what
is the biggest lessons that you've
learned over your 10 years of being an
actress and working in Mexico and now in
Hollywood that you should always feel
proud of every single step that you do
there's no small things in life for like
you know
there's a stigma about how doing soap
operas and I'm like soap operas prepped
me I would have never been ready for
this the things that you learn the the
the discipline and the worth of the work
ethic that you have to have at 13 and a
soap opera that keeps on going every
single day and having to shoot a hundred
scene that's a lesson that prepped me to
be really well prepared for when it came
to America every single step down the
line has been just a massive lesson to
me and like what and what not to do
yeah exactly and I'm just happy
[Music]